let's suppose you're interviewing a
theater owner you've got your movie
you've got it
gut questions you don't want to give
away this precious baby to just anyone
what questions are you asking I would
ask a theater owner if they're happy if
they are doing what they thought they
would be doing really if you're happy
yeah well there are people who I think
personally I think used-car salesmen who
own the lot are happier than the number
one salesman at whoever and whoever
Chevrolet or whoever whoever Chrysler
Dodge or Dodge or who yeah because
they're the ones that they go out and
they make deals on on inventory they
bring the inventory in and they know the
vehicles they know which ones run they
know which ones don't they know the high
mileage cars the low mileage cars and
know where the knocks are they know all
that and they are under so they're
educated on their product and they are
proud on some level of their product and
they they rely on a relationship with
their customer base they're not gonna
lie to somebody about some you know the
third yellow it's yellow that's not a
lemon it's just yellow when they know it
doesn't really work they know it's not
gonna get these folks home so to me
those are people because you're gonna
come back to them and say hey Bobby
what's up with this suburban you said it
would run it doesn't didn't get me home
they don't want that they want you to
come by and say hey I was at the
doughnut shop and I brought you a cup of
coffee in my new suburban and that great
thanks Bobby I have to think that people
maybe I'm naive but I have to think that
on some level the most basic level of
human kind that's how they want to feel
they want to be proud about what they do
they don't want to do what they're told
they don't want to they don't want to
and so that I would think would boil
down to people who own 16 or 32 Plex
down the street they've got a lot of
money invested and it's not to say that
they're gonna shift don't I mean it's no
they're not like kick everybody out
right they're still gonna make their
money with the big boys
but the creative part of them I think is
lacking and I think
that's what hopefully they're gonna see
or entreat them about what our slate of
films that we're bringing them and it's
not just our slate it's other filmmakers
and hopefully creating more of a
collective group of filmmakers be an
avenue for independent filmmakers to
actually be able to get on a big screen
right Alabama in North Carolina wherever
wherever it is instead of being told
when they can show stuff and then being
limited now it's a way to almost
piggyback little movies on yes so are
you happy yeah when i did when i when i
released collier and company worked with
the theater chain out of Georgia and I
moved the prints from theater to theater
to theater and wherever I showed up I
did radio interviews and television
interviews and we out sold whatever
movie whatever big studio movie was in
the theatre for that evening only for
that evening but that was good
we had people watching the movie people
enjoying it people buying popcorn
theater owner was happy I as a creative
person was being fed and an audience was
enjoying themselves and they still come
to me and say hey I saw a Collier and
company in Savannah Georgia and it was
great when he gonna make another one
that makes me feel great so much more so
than hey I saw you in some movie I don't
even know where I I did it because you
know my little cardboard sign and I'm an
actor it says will will act for food
right I much prefer the other and I have
to believe like I said I have to believe
basic human nature you don't get in the
automobile business if you hate cars you
don't get in the movie theater business
if you don't like to see people with the
wait on the on the front of their seats
watching something that excites them and
taking them away you have to be that
kind of person inside I I believe that
you did it has to be true and if it's
not then we're wrong and we'll build a
drive-in which will build the drive-in
we'll do it over we'll do it ourselves
and we'll have the weight on
on the Front's of our butts okay so are
you happy so that was so suppose they're
they're just grinning from ear to ear
and they're not a place for us okay I
mean they but they seem happy right but
if they say that they're if they're if
they're if there's no void to be filled
and obviously there's no room but I do
think that there's yeah we're looking
it's it's all over Anderson bench are
you are you content Anderson what
content is any exist of course I'm not
right they're having a good day but of
course I'm not do you ever think you
could be said why bother
but if I could have one content day I
could die a happy man and I think sadly
that's where a lot of people live they
don't think they deserve to be happy
they don't deserve to be content it's
not possible to wake up in the morning
and do what you love to do we think
quite different it's not possible not to
wake up in the morning it's it's not
possible to wake up in the morning and
not do what you love to do the same
thing you were thinking about when you
went to sleep it's the same thing you
start doing when you wake up in the
morning and that's how that's how we're
living and it's a choice it's not it
we're not lucky we're not fortunate we
haven't been hit with the with a lucky
stick we just refuse to believe
otherwise keep working and that's what
Anderson bench is about in in a very
real way now will people will people see
that when they see the movie all the way
through I'm fascinated to find out
Anderson bench was born of the question
if you knew beyond a shadow of a doubt
that you had just lived the best day of
your life not just the best day you've
ever had but the best day you will ever
have
how would you end it
yeah and he talks about just warning
when he is questioned just wanting to
make it through without screwing things
up yeah yeah yeah that's a goal
Anderson sorry yeah yeah you know people
deserve better than that she says that
you deserve to be happy you should be
happy and it kind of puffs a little wind
in his sails there are two kinds of
people in the world I think there are
people who well they're three people
people who who do nothing people who
take knives to every sale that they see
and and cut a hole in the middle so it
can be less effective and people who
blow wind in your sails to help you get
down the road so which one are you
theater owner car salesman which one of
those people are you that's what I want
to know and those are the those those
are the concepts that that are around
the movies we make so let's suppose
ideal wise personality wise you mesh
with this theater owner what are some
other questions you're asking because
you can have a great relationship with
someone like them but maybe the business
side of it isn't for you so what are
some questions do you think you'd ask as
well what do you need what can we do for
you right absolutely
I mean it's also you know our approach
to how we're going to feed and promote
and relationships that we're calling
upon and it's a lot of different things
all right what are you what are you
looking for and it's what do you need is
not something that people are used to
being asked everybody goes to to these
sorts of well nobody's really having
these sorts of meetings but basically a
meeting is about me trying to get
something from you and I think that's
wrong so again we're inverting that
model to this meeting is about what can
we give to you what do you need and how
can we help you get it and also work
cooperatively don't I mean I think
that's where the the shift is and it's
the same way with
our approach to filmmaking - is that
most people are you know when we start
talking about screenplays here to agents
and stuff like that they were like you
know the first thing is financing and
then how can they help get financing
it's like no we already have our
financing everything we do is very
atypical yeah and including how we're
marketing and how we're gonna deal with
the theater owners without giving too
much away it's a very atypical approach
when we started Children's Miracle
Network we were something that hospitals
needed and didn't even realize they
needed it and we're in the service
business that's it we raise money for
Children's Hospital don't tell them how
to use it don't even suggest how they
use it totally non discretionary funding
unheard of now it's been unheard of for
34 years and we've raised over five
billion dollars with not a single string
or thread attached to any single dollar
that we've raised same thing with this
model this model is your your grant I
heard a wonderful story the other day
about this guy's grandpa who started
this this theater chain who was a mayor
and he dressed up like Boss Hogg from
dukes and he was heavy and everybody
loved him and he was that he was a
showman and this is a guy who started a
very successful theater chain and it's
become it went from showman grandpa to
business business business business
still wonderful showman family but
there's there there's a lot of business
involved and
okay they love that I guarantee you no
one has ever sat in the office in their
office and said what can we do for you
and that boils down to when you were a
kid what watch what kind of movies if
you could cut one screen off of all of
the screens that you have and dedicate
it to something that would make you
smile what would that be
they'll tell us and we either have it or
we'll find it or we'll make it
you